première décision juridique un recours
sera déposé contre cette décision du
tribunal administratif devant le conseil
d'état par cap nord laisse mds aussi
pourrait être visée par une action en
justice dans le cadre de la consultation
lorsque vous indiquez que vous avez 4
quarante-et-une personnes et que si
cette base là que l'on travaille et que
lorsque vous n'êtes pas retenu vous
annoncer cette personne de plus il faut
que vous expliquer d'où elles sortent si
elle était là pourquoi vous les avez pas
déclarés et là il faut voir les réponses
vous proposer en tout cas à cap nord de
faire un recours juridique lundi de ne
pas laisser les choses en l'état
ce serait trop facile pour continuer la
distribution en eau potable
un avenant sera signée avec l'asm ds
opérateurs historiques de la zone avant
la mise en place d'une régie
communautaire prévue dans quatre ans la
laiterie le gall a valu tant de monde de
l'art de jouer cette musique
en résumé deux procès un audit pour
cerner la possibilité d'aller vers une
régie le prolongement de la délégation
de service public de l'asm ds pour
justin pamphile mère du lorrain cette
stratégie manque le site d'analysé de
sagesse la décision la plus sage ce
matin on était simplement de ne pas
partir dans une procédure administrative
juridique qui va être longue et de
simplement voir comment nous pouvons
accélérer en respectant les obligations
réglementaires qui seront les nôtres
la procédure d'arriver à la régie et
pour faire en sorte que l'eau va
continuer à prouver dans de bonnes et de
meilleures conditions pour les
contribuables cap nord a jusqu'au 1er
juillet pour s'organiser
c'est la date à laquelle le changement
de fermi aurait dû s'opérer